Democrats are moving to expel the
embattled and eccentric Republican
Congressman George Santos George Santos
has been under Fire because he appears
to have lied about everything in his
past and defrauded a lot of people and
there was a house ethics investigation
and it's not looking good for the guy
and
uh well anyway here's their argument Mr
Speaker pursuant to Clause 2a1 of rule 9
arise to give notice of my intent to
raise a question of the Privileges of
the house the form of the resolution is
as follows house resolution
114 resolved that pursuant to Article 1
Section 5 Clause 2 of The Constitution
of the United States Representative
George Santos be and he hereby is
expelled from the House of
Representatives thank you Mr Speaker we
have to expel him and why do we have to
expel George Santos from our nation's
highest legislative body well he lied
apparently about his ethnic background
he used a funny phrase a phrase that I
used too he said he was Jewish but there
doesn't seem to be evidence that he's
Jewish or so
okay has any other member of the lower
or upper chamber of the United States
Congress ever done such a thing would
you do that does that ring a bell at all
would someone who was one
1,28 n American would would anyone like
that ever uh remain a sitting United
States Senator oh right yeah the Dems do
that well you see uh George Santos he
took money
inappropriately oh yeah do you think any
Democrat would ever do that hey let's
check Nancy B's portfolio how's that
looking that's she made a lot of money
for being in government her whole life
let's go further let's check Bob
menendez's portfolio Bob Menendez New
Jersey Democrat Senator he's still there
right why wait hold on but we got to
kick out George Santos that seems a
little strange the problem with
criticizing George Santos is not that
he's innocent he's not it's not that he
didn't commit serious crimes he did I
mean he he appears to have committed
fraud I consider I and Dante the Divine
poet consider fraud to be basically the
worst sin you can possibly commit
defrauding uh betraying one's
benefactors is the sort of thing that in
Dante's Divine Comedy gets you put into
the mouth of Satan in the river kitis
being gwed by the the chief of the
Devils for all of all of eternity so
yeah it's that's
bad the problem is that the Democrats do
all the same
stuff so I'm I'm not saying I would
endorse the guy to run again I'm not
saying I'm going to send him a campaign
donation certainly not I don't want my
identity stolen
but why would I call on him to resign
when the Democrats get away with all the
same stuff with impunity at a much
higher level for a much longer time the
only reason that the Li are going after
DeSantis
DeSantis D Santos not DeSantis he's a
good guy the reason they're going after
Santos is
because we have a very slim Republican
majority in the house and they think if
they can Whittle away at that then it's
going to be easier to stop the
Republicans from obstructing Biden's
agenda that's all it's about and so for
that reason it's going to come up for a
vote maybe up for a vote already
today and I think it would be crazy for
Republicans to vote to expel him I agree
that he deserves to be expelled I'm not
in any way defending
Santos for the crimes that he would seem
quite obviously to have
committed but they're not throwing him
out of Congress for the crimes he's
committed they're throwing him out of
Congress in a really cynical political
Ploy and they're not throwing out their
own members who have done similar things
so no I think every Republican should
vote to keep Santos in office the reason
in particular is that he says he won't
run for office again so this is c l
about this Congress it's a two-year term
it's not going to be going on for much
longer he'll be out of office soon
enough maybe then a republican will have
a chance to mount a strong campaign but
if you kick out Santos now if the
Democrats do muster enough Republicans
to have a two-third vote to expel then
there's going to be a special election
in New York and some Dem is going to
replace them most likely why would we do
that why why do Republicans always
willingly just hand over power to
Democrats on some Mis mistaken
understanding of principle that is
really no principle at all right now go
to shop
beam.com the holidays are here the last
thing that you need during this busy
time of year is to miss out on a great
night's sleep that is why our team loves
beams dream powder beams dream powder
contains a powerful all natural blend of
ingredients including magnesium L
theanine it is not just your
run-of-the-mill sleep aid it is a
concoction carefully crafted to help you
slip into the sweet Embrace of rest
without the grogginess that often
accompanies other sleep remedies sleep
is the foundation of our mental and
physical health you must have a
consistent nighttime routine to function
at your best today our listeners get a
special discount on beams dream powder
their bestselling hot cocoa for sleep
with no added sugar now available in
delicious flavors like cinnamon cocoa
chocolate peanut butter and mint chip
better sleep has never tasted better
just mix beam dream into hot water or
milk stir or froth and enjoy before
bedtime ooh sounds cozy if you find
yourself battling the Bedtime Blues give
it a shot your weary self will thank you
try beams bestselling dream powder take
advantage of their biggest sale of the
Year get up to 50 5% off for a limited
time when you go to shop
beam.com discount is auto applied to
checkout no code necessary that is shop
beam.com kwes for 50% off a newborn baby
was surrendered to and safely retrieved
from a baby box in Indiana have you I've
covered baby boxes on this show before
baby boxes are this kind of silly but
really important uh innovation in public
policy which is for people who have a
baby but don't want the baby instead of
leaving it outside at a fire department
where it could dive exposure instead of
throwing it in a trash can which happens
instead of killing the baby you just
surrender the baby to a nice warm
climate controlled box where the baby
will then be accepted anonymously and
then uh given to an adoptive couple that
that actually wants to take care of the
baby and so far this year uh seven
babies have been surrendered in Indiana
alone in in these baby boxes 16 across
the country and this is a very new
policy it's not in a lot of places I I
met the guy actually who pioneered this
idea uh that the baby will likely be
adopted by a family within 30 to 45 days
this is really beautiful stuff you know
there there are seven babies in the
state of Indiana there seven human
beings who will look back one day and
say wow that policy is responsible for
me being alive most likely wow that's a
reminder
that polit that the law is a teacher
that
politics can can shape human behavior of
course that laws will of course shape
human behavior and they have very very
practical tangible effects it's not just
you know the economic forecasts 30 years
into the future it's hey is that human
being going to be alive or is that human
being going to be killed as a baby what
what's it going to be we're incarnate
creatures it's it's a reminder how many
people commit more horrible crimes
because of
Shame think about that this this woman
who surrendered her baby didn't want to
keep the baby might have felt some shame
that she got knocked up in in other
circumstances if that baby box were out
there she might have she might have
killed the baby disposed of the baby to
to which is a far more heinous crime
than you know sleeping out of wedlock or
something but a lot of people do that
and so we in our public policy we need
to account for that and we can pass laws
to change Behavior change the view of uh
the the value of human life boy what a
great clip that was now hey hey hey hey
hold up hey did you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time